Hey, here we are,
almost at the end of the
season. In this video we
will finish our pig trailer,
including the challenge for the
recycle plastic switches,
but first we will clear around our
community center
with a very satisfying timelapse
And also
this is going to be our last
sponsored video of
the season, this time by
Surf Shark VPN.
Again. So there's a lot of stuff
happening, going to be a long
video. Welcome to a new Project Kamp update.
This big ruin is
what we call our community
center. We found it
the first year and we cleared
it all around. We
thought let´s renovated as a
workspace. A lot of
potential. Then in season two,
we decided it will
serve better as a community
center. Now in
season three we realized we need
to build it from
scratch. But nature doesn't
mind our plans and
slowly takes over the area.
So we need to maintain the place clean
meanwhile. If you want
to know more about our plans,
you can check
update 98. And if you want to
know more about
nature, then keep on watching.
First we are going
to tackle this huge pile
of brambles that is
shielding in the view from the
community center. This
pile was actually left here
by the last time they
work in the community center.
Thanks Julie. One meter and a bit of just
dead wood, a pile of
dead wood. And then on top,
one another meter and a half of
brambles and ferns all tangled up together.
I wouldn't wish this on my worst
enemy. Want to take a dive in?
Okay, so to give
it a bit of a boost in the
beginning, we're
going to use the brush cutter.
And we want to walk
over the pile as far as we can.
Beautiful morning
guys. How are we doing? Lovely.
Look what we found here
under the pile of
dead wood. We have two tires,
And the other one.
Oh, why am I´m starting
recording that? Oh my god, she went real far.
It's coming back. Oh
no, she's gone. She keeps going.
Oh, we could place money on this.
I thought we could have a race.
So first step is
done. The pile is gone. Now
we can move to the
next step. This big mimosas.
So as you can see, these mimosas
are like really close to the structure.
So normally they are blocking the view.
They're making working
here harder. It's also like a
risk because they can fall any
moment. So they have to go. Goodbye big girls.
So our next step
before moving inside
of the community
center is going to be brush
cut all of these ferns
and weeds that are around here.
Let me be man.
Let me play my solitaire.
Nice game.
Done.
Finito.
Nice.
So the wall of brambles has been removed.
The ferns have been flattened and the
mimosas are down which
means we can now move on to
take on the inside
of the community center.
If you've been
following the channel you'll
know that we already
tackled this quite extensively
last season.
However as you can see
the bloody brambles have returned.
So let's get cracking.
This is one of the
rooms on the right of the
community centre
and as you can see there's
an interesting work tank in the
shape here in the middle on the little stairs.
Guessing it was used
for livestock back in the day.
So we're going to brush cut all these brambles away and then place them in the middle, let´s them dry out
and perhaps we can burn them later
Get in there Màtè.
Alright, the inside of the community center is now clean.
So the big pile is gone, the
ferns cut and the community center cleared.
Now we are going to control the
mimosas that are growing in the back.
Also there are a
lot of dead trees that were
cut by the
municipality when clearing under
the electricity lines.
Looks quite dangerous.
Here we are at the
back of the community center.
This area was already cleared last
year but as you can see it's pretty overgrown.
So let's get to work.
I feel like I chopped
at least 200 mimosas there.
All right, so we're
almost done clearing this space
behind the community center.
As you can see, we have
cleared a lot of the mimosas
and there's a lot more
space here for us to wander around.
But unfortunately we
have to pause our efforts for now
as we discovered a
very angry hornet's nest
right in the back over there.
And we're just
waiting for the fire department
to come and take care of it.
Not sure if you can see it,
but it's this beige
basketball that's hanging there
between the mimosas.
Oh, it's already on zoom.
So the wasp busters have
arrived to take care of them.
In the next five days,
we need to check on the hives
and see if they still have hornets inside
or if it's really empty, fingers crossed.
So it has been quite some time ago
since they came to treat the wasp nest.
And as you might see in
the back, no wasps around anymore.
So as you have seen,
we have been working a lot
around the community
center, but we got stuck here.
In general, actually, the
land is a lot of work to maintain.
And we mainly do this all by hand,
but we have some good news around this.
- Ha, I didn't
even realize you were there.
We need to talk about Surfshark,
the sponsor of this video.
Surfshark is a virtual private network,
an app that helps you
surf the internet in a safe way,
changing your IP
address and encrypting your data.
If you go for Surfshark one package,
you also get a search
tool that doesn't track you,
nor show any ads, an antivirus,
and you get notified
if your data is being leaked
all in one account.
Surfshark can be
useful because most of us
come from different
places around the world.
You want to see Netflix content
only available on your home country?
Switch on Surfshark VPN, and now you can.
Thanks to the IP change and encryption,
you get an extra layer of privacy
for sensitive
information like card numbers,
personal data or passwords.
Very useful for remote team works,
where you need to
share this kind of info.
Especially if you are
connected to a sketchy public wifi,
which we used to do a
lot in the early days here.
Surfshark is easy to use,
accepts an unlimited number of devices,
and is compatible
with all operative systems.
And now you can get a Black Friday deal
with our code ProjectK.
And you get up to six
months extra with your subscription.
And if you don't like it,
you have 30 days money back guarantee.
Check the link in the description.
- Okay, it's good.
- Woo hoo!
Okay, so we just did four ads.
That means that now we
can buy ourselves a tractor.
We are not decided
whether to buy a tractor or a digger.
We are still deciding.
You can check the research
module where we talk about that.
Yeah, but now let's
continue with the video.
In previous updates,
we bought this old rusty pig trailer.
We restored it and
built the house on top of it.
We just finished the outside,
ready for the first rains of the autumn.
And we can work in the interior.
With Julien and Colline, our French team,
we will work hard to finish the house.
Let's start.
Okay, back in the trailer.
Now that we have done the paneling,
we want to separate one
bedroom and one living area.
For this wall, we're
gonna use leftover paneling
and some beams that arrive today.
And we're also
gonna use to close the space,
a sliding door that we found.
Let's get do it.
These are the beam
that we received today.
There are four of them,
and we're gonna use
them to make the whole structure.
We're done with the
first part of the inside wall.
And for the second one,
we thought it would be nice for us
to use the leftover
wood that we have already.
So with Julien, we're gonna go over it
and pick the
pieces that we like the most,
the color that we
fancy, the type of texture we want,
get this all in the pig trailer and start
this weird mosaic of leftover.
Okay.
Now this part is done.
Next, this sort of rectangle, this shape.
I tried to do something less complex
because all of this
angle is brain, brain ache.
So let's do the top part.
So now it's almost finished.
We need to hide this part of the socket.
I need to cut.
I've made all the cut here.
A little here just for this piece.
Put in and see if it fits.
Now time to do this piece.
Nice.
Okay, so all the mosaic is done.
Maybe the most
difficult part was this part
because that was all the leftover,
of the leftover.
I like this little
bookshelf we can remove it if we want.
But my favorite
part is still this corner.
This was a nice way
to reuse our wood leftovers.
With some
dedication, Julien create this mosaic
that is such a
contrast with the outside looks
of the pig trailer.
Next, we are going to
install a stove for the winter.
So now we have all the pieces
that are gonna be in our chimney.
An isolated pipe, pipe from the old oven
we made in the season one.
Some adapters,
pieces to make it a bit nicer.
Time to go through
the wall and see what happens.
Little add of insulation.
A window.
And here we can see all
the layers of the pig trailer.
We have trespa, battens, foil,
OSB, insulation, foil, and the paneling.
So to go through the
wall and through the insulation,
we will put an extra layer of insulation
with aluminum foil around.
Hey.
Hello.
Be careful.
Now it's time to
install the rest of the chimney.
So we have some leftovers from the oven,
some new pieces, some
connections, and time to go up.
Not the most stetic job we ever done,
but it's almost about to rain again.
So we hope that at
least stay dry everything.
Now that we have the pipe,
Dave's gonna make
a heat wall in the inside.
So we're currently
at the local granite place
where they cut stone to make things.
You can buy many different things.
Seems like a lot of people here use it
to make their gravestones.
And we're gonna try to find some leftover
to make around the stove.
And they have
quite a few funny leftovers.
Let me show you.
So you have some decoration,
many very small leftovers.
Jesus. Wisdom.
A very old person.
Some random off-cut shapes.
And a book.
Stone book.
So they also have
all these kind of off-cuts
which are much longer.
They come from the bigger sheets
and they all have different types.
So you have them thick and gray,
bit more colored,
polished with a rough edge, very thin.
And also a few pieces of marble.
So it's quite a cool, diverse mix.
And the different
color of granite depends
on which different region it comes from.
So I think we're gonna
try to put them all together
in a row in the
back wall with some screws
so we can create a heat
resistant back wall for the stove.
So here we are back in the workspace
with a nice selection of stones.
I have one
noteworthy one, I think it´s cool.
It's like this piece of marble,
but it's so thin.
It's impressive that it's made of stone.
But besides that, we have a whole bunch
of different
thicknesses, colors, textures.
So should look funky.
Now what we're gonna
do next is to drill a hole
that we can mount it on the wall.
The guy said it's
quite difficult to drill holes.
He would recommend
adhesive or cement to put it together.
But we don't like that.
We try to avoid these things.
And also with the heat of the stove,
it's probably just better to have
a more mechanical solution.
So we're gonna try to drill a hole.
So for this, we have a
diamond drill, a drill, some water,
and a leftover piece
that apparently needs to go
underneath the granite to make sure
it doesn't crack when you go through.
So if you put in a screw now,
it still sticks out a little bit here.
So we're gonna give it a
little chamfer with a bigger drill.
But actually one
much smoother than expected.
So I guess we're just
gonna continue drilling all of them.
So we're currently in the house,
brought the granite here,
and we need to install all of this.
So it's gonna be a bit of puzzling,
especially around the chimney.
It's gonna be harder
because it would still need
to cut the granite to work around it.
And so it's just gonna
be a bit of a freestyle puzzle
to cover off the wall.
So we're gonna take a piece of granite.
They're all in very different sizes.
So we're roughly gonna
hammer it here in the right size.
Once the size is
good, we're gonna put them here.
The first piece is a bit of a rough one,
just because it's cool.
And on the bottom, we don't have a hole
because it was a
bit too much work to drill.
So we're gonna use some leftover wood
to chop a little block.
It's really just a simple little block.
And this is gonna go on the bottom
to secure the granite
and make sure it stays in place.
And later, once all the granite is in,
we're gonna build a
little bit of a platform
where the stove will be on.
So the blocks will be covered.
So now comes the most challenging part,
going around the chimney pipe
because it means cutting the granite
and drilling a few extra holes.
But luckily, I already did that.
So now we can just assemble everything
and hopefully it fits.
So far so good.
I think we're going a little bit angled
because this one is not super straight.
But I think it should be okay.
Cool, all fits.
Next, you need to put
these little blocks on the bottom
to make sure they're secure.
So here's the chimney hole.
As you can see, it's cutted around it,
but not super accurate.
Not a pro granite cutter yet.
But luckily it's very common thing
that is hard to go
around the chimney pipe.
So you have these things to cover it up.
Not sure if I like that thing,
but it should be functional now.
So the wall is in place.
Next, we're gonna make the bottom part.
This is gonna be a little bit challenging
because I didn't wanna
drill too many holes in the granite.
So the floor is
gonna be against the granite.
But as you can see,
the granite all
has different thicknesses.
So we need to make the bottom plate
and cut out all the edges
of the different granite thicknesses,
which I think still is
easier than cutting all the granite,
but I'm not sure how
this next step is gonna be.
So for the floor,
we're gonna use some leftover metal
that was originally in the trailer.
Right there is the pile I had in mind.
And there's this big aluminum sheet.
So it is the front
side with the relive up,
Hard to clean.
This is the back.
You still see the
pattern, but it's smooth.
So it should be a bit more convenient.
So now I'm gonna
measure all the granite pieces
and draw them all
in so we can cut it out.
After taking the measures,
I started cutting
and fitting the metal sheet.
Then some polishing.
And I built a base
with some wooden leftovers.
Still had to drill some more holes
to attach the metal sheet to the base.
And last, some wood
finishing for the edges.
So the area for the stove is now ready.
Aluminum sheet here,
wooden finishing around it.
So next step is to install the stove,
but first we need to clean it up
and I'm gonna get some help for that.
Yeah.
I got this stove from someone last year.
Has been outside for the whole year,
so we need to do
something with it, try to repair it.
Legs are very rusty.
We need to clean the glass.
Some screws missing.
And clean the inside.
Okay, now we have heat in the house.
Quite essential for
the dark and cold winter nights
that are coming.
Also quite essential is light.
And for that, we need light switches.
They're actually
pretty hard to find secondhand.
It always feels a bit painful
having to buy this from new plastic,
especially knowing that we're gonna need
many more of those in the future.
So a few months ago, we put out a call
to Precious Plastic
Community to try and develop one
in a little contest.
For anyone that is able to make a mold,
to inject with a Precious Plastic machine,
you can get a thousand euros
for the first one that
shows us a working light switch.
And we had a winner.
So we just received
the package from Johannplasto
from Germany and he made
some cool light switches.
Nice, he says like
how much plastic we recycled.
342 grams.
He also has a
website, make sure to check it out.
Look nicely packed.
Here's the first type of switch.
Looks really nice.
And here's another type.
It's a bit bigger.
All are made from polypropylene.
And the difference is that one--
gets in the wall, so it's covered.
And one with an
enclosure, so it's an outside switch.
So you can mount it when
you don't have a double wall.
Let's see what they
look like when we open them up.
Three injected
parts made with precious plastic
and one off-the-shelf piece
to make sure it all functions well.
Here you can see how they're made.
First making a 3D
model with the exact sizes.
Then a 3D printer mold is used
so you can make a quick injection
to see if all the
measurements are correct.
And overall, this
is still a first prototype
to see if everything works properly.
And you can download all
the drawings open source online
in the precious plastic
community if you want to replicate it.
For now, we're going to
install them and see how they work.
Hopefully all good and
we can make a final proper mold
so we can use it in
Project Kamp for the long term.
Injecting our own
plastic waste into useful items.
Now, Adrián will install them.
So, let's see if it works.
It works, looks nice.
But we noticed some little details
that maybe doesn't work that good.
It's still a prototype.
You've seen how the mold is done.
So it's the version one of this.
It wiggles a bit here.
And we noticed that
probably the fitting of these pieces
is not perfect in these holes.
Normal when you
work with these materials.
But we will keep on using it.
Try it out because
that's what we do here.
Try out things.
And try to improve it in the future
to see if we can
make something very satisfying
to press.
Happy to see Precious
Plastic being useful in Project kamp.
And also happy we're
getting closer to the end.
We just need to take
care of a few more final details.
And we still have
two problems with the door.
One is that we don't
have anything to open it up.
So at the moment we use a screwdriver.
And second, this doesn't lock properly
because it's just this piece of wood
which probably is
gonna wear out over time.
So it's better if there's some metal
on there to lock the door properly.
So I found this
nice piece of stainless steel
from a broken spatula.
Used to be one of
these things in the kitchen
to flip the food like
SpongeBob on his burgers
But it broke over here on the edge.
No problem, we got a new one.
But now I can use this piece of metal
to make the holder for the door.
So it's gonna be something like this
with a hole inside
for the door to lock in.
And two screws so we can attach it.
Next, we're gonna
use this leftover material
from the pig trailer
to make a little door handle.
Okay, door handle done.
We just need some finished touches
and Julien seems the right guy to do it.
Here we have a little space, little gap.
Just like here.
I have already cut this piece
because it comes from a bigger leftover.
Just this part.
Cut, screw, and it's done.
That was easy.
Next room now.
It's done.
So here, you can see we have a gap
between the paneling and the window.
So now we need to put some little pieces
of wood.
The pieces of wood are cut.
Now I need to cut the side of the window.
It's cold.
I'm gonna sand all of this piece of wood
inside the room so it's not really good.
That's why ear protection, mask,
it's never too much against the dust.
Okay.
So the edge of the door is finished.
Everything is finished.
All the finishing are finished.
So,
see you.
Okay, we just finished the building,
but we still need to clean a bit.
And now the pig trailer is finished,
ready to be used
by the team in the winter.
It has been an
adventure and we learned a lot
on how to renovate and build with reuse
and recycled materials.
It certainly brings
limitations and challenges
and sometimes you have
to go through the usual way,
but we will keep
improving in the projects to come.
And that was it for this update.
The next one will
be the last of this season,
where we are going
to do some big land works
before the winter comes, everybody leaves
and the rain takes over.
If you want to see it right now,
you can support us in
Patreon and in the future,
probably be part of the decision making,
like the choosing of
the colors of this pig trailer.
If not, you can
subscribe to the YouTube channel.
Thanks for watching
and see you in the next update.